when I first got diagnosed I could not
look at myself in the mirror because I
knew there'd be a person staring back at
me saying
how are you going to deal with this
situation am I going to survive the next
six to seven months to meet my son
that was a really big thing
I'm Tom I'm 34 and I'm a Survivor of a
rare Hodgkin's lymphoma
[Music]
it was around Christmas 2018
Courtney my fiance it was eight weeks
pregnant
all of a sudden she just rocked up one
day to my work with a pregnancy test
that she
furthest thing for our mind was having
kids to be honest we were all about that
Adventure life and just being fit and
healthy and active
I think it was maybe two three days
after Christmas I kind of fell into my
armpit and I just felt this huge lump
under there
went to a doctor she sort of gave me an
initial rough diagnosis
the first thing I did is I got in my car
and I drove around the corner I stopped
and I called my mum I just rang her and
I said I think they think the doctor
thinks I've got cancer
she just went quiet and um
yeah I got really upset I sort of broke
down because I don't know what how to
feel about it I don't know like why like
it was just like thoughts were just
rushing through my head immediately like
you know like my first thought is am I
going to meet my child
my mum runs sort of our close family and
a couple of my close mates and they all
sort of came around
it was funny because one of my mates was
smoking at the time we sort of went on
the balcony and had a chat about it and
they were really positive and supportive
and I said give me a cigarette he's like
what I was like I've already got cancer
I actually saw a lot of external help
psychologically
I think there was always that stigma of
like you know does it make me a weak
person or a vulnerable person having to
see a psychologist but I knew that you
know getting my mindset in the right
place would involve actually talking to
an expert
so I did a couple of cycles of the
chemotherapy it's actually funny because
when I started chemo all the symptoms
that I would get were exactly the same
as pregnancy yeah like the nausea not
being able to eat certain foods the
energy like it was kind of a positive
funny running joke that we had through
the whole process I'd be like Oh I'm
feeling like this today she's like me
too
I had a stem cell transplant and I was
having a really difficult time breathing
they put me into ICU because they didn't
really know what was going on
I had this one specialist he said we're
giving you probably between a five and
fifteen percent chance of making it
through this
you know which is tough to hear yeah I
would get quite emotional sort of
thinking that we'd get to this situation
where Courtney would be a single mum you
know
[Music]
the whole process of being hospital for
a long period of time is quite hard and
isolating it's like a time capsule it's
really hard for me to figure out what
was daytime what was night time so I had
to do a lot of reading and meditating
the mindset and the toughness of Jiu
Jitsu really helped me pull through and
remain in a positive and calm headspace
I walked out of Hospital on my birthday
with my newborn son I would easily say
that's probably one of the greatest days
of my life
one of the things that gave me the drive
to make sure that I got through the
process
so as far as my condition goes I'm in
revision which is the classes cured I
guess in some aspects
it took a couple of years but I'm back
fully active back to Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
which was a really massive highlight for
me I'm addicted again and can't stop
training
looking back at that period of my life
I think it's probably the best thing
that ever happened to me which sounds
strange because it was such a hard thing
to go through but it makes you realize
what's important and what's not
important
I was a person that really didn't handle
stress that well now I've probably
nearly completely abolished it from my
life being really grateful and living in
the present moment is a big aspect of
that
I know I can deal with difficult
situations well I go there yep there's a
bit of drama around it that I got there
[Applause]
[Music]
if anything that I've said resonates
with you or you'd like to read more
please check out the links below